one of the greatest shooters of all time
Dennis Scott NBA TV analyst he continues
the finals pre and postgame coverage
tonight on NBA TV and starting at 7:00
Eastern Charles Barkley and C Webb and
Grant Hill will be there for Game four
dennis joins us this morning Dennis what
is left to decide here aside from how
many games Golden State wins in the
warriors have found their groove LeBron
has been great if you listened to his
presser yesterday he broke down both
teams perfectly on how good they are
from top to bottom and he understands
that he can do whatever he needs to do
but if Kevin Love and the rest of those
guys don't make shots I think it's safe
to say you can go to your closet and
bring out the broom did it feel like an
exit interview from Cleveland yesterday
by LeBron
that's a great question Dan to my point
like I think LeBron has told all of us
that he's done all he could do he's been
the best leader all year long the Cavs
that basically had what three different
teams throughout the season yeah no we
lost him Dennis got lost on a switch
there see if we can get him back but I
saw Charles Barkley and see Webb and
Grant Hill with NBA TV
do we have LeBron he had three
interviews yeah do we what do we have
from LeBron that's is there anything
juicy on there as to him talking about
this season as a whole okay we'll get to
that and then we'll bring back Dennis
gun there's been one or two the most
challenging you know seasons of my
career from a standpoint of what's going
on all of our ballclub only from a
no planned perspective but you know
things you know God's changed in
personnel is changing our coach of being
out for a couple weeks players leaving
being up for a couple weeks
injuries things of that nature us having
a very great couple months then not
playing so well and then trace happening
things of that nature he also talked
about facing a super team and then you
wonder if he's sort of setting the table
to join a super team or create a super
team that was the feeling I got and
maybe I read too much into this do you
have lebron talking about super teams
everyone's trying to figure that out how
do you put together a group of talent
but also a group of minds as well to be
able to compete with go to state to be
able to compete for a championship yeah
not gonna create that in Cleveland just
sounds like he's resigned to the fact of
ya didn't want to do it but I gotta do
it I gotta go and join a super team yes
you sound so silly to say but you really
especially if you're somebody like
LeBron you want to be around people that
understand the game and know where
you're supposed to be and that's not
even at jr. Smith thing it's just people
who understand how to move with the ball
and understand situational basketball
and and all those things well he has a
high basketball IQ maybe higher than
most great players and then it's got to
be even more frustrating when you're
well you don't even have to have an IQ
to know what the score is you would
think in a game but the other stuff of
trying to get guys even you know Jeff
Van Gundy talking about Rodney hood the
other night he goes he doesn't even know
what he's doing out there he's running
in the wrong direction but he did give
them energy
yes week loved it I had a poll option
that's probably unfair but do you think
LeBron James will ever win another title
if you think about that it seems like
yeah he's 33 of course he is but with
the Warriors being miss dominant he
might get boxed out here I don't it's
not gonna be easy for even him to form a
super team well I did say earlier this
year or maybe it was last year that I
don't think LeBron will ever win another
MVP and and the reason being now he
could have wanted this year and I think
he's the most valuable player in the
league it feels like every year he's the
most valuable player but you know James
Harden it was his time and it's almost
like winning the Academy
like an actor can't win it when you're
young you gotta wait you got to put in
your time and maybe you win for
something that maybe you shouldn't have
won for James Harden
you know the MVP no problem with that
Russell Westbrook jr. the third last
year no problem with that either but
with LeBron I don't know if we're ever
going to look at it and go boy that's an
MVP like season because if this year
wasn't then when is he going to have one
of those as far as winning a
championship
if Golden State can keep everybody
together money-wise because if I'm
looking at steps gonna be forty million
dollars a year
Durant's gonna be 35 36 million dollars
a year and unless you have a hard cap in
the NBA and you have an owner who is
going to be willing to spend and have
that luxury tax
I mean what's klay Thompson worth and
then draymond Green and what he's worth
did you see and I said this yesterday
everybody looks at Golden State goes oh
they got those four guys you're going to
see guys who go be kind of fun to play
there I may not make my money but I got
a chance like David West and I can play
for a championship
I saw where Trevor Ariza is looking at
maybe joining Golden State could you
imagine how valuable that would be to
get Trevor Ariza and now you may go why
don't Trevor reason no when you get
those guys and get them at a bargain
price oh my goodness yeah McLovin
someone told me that when durant signed
for less money maybe was it last year or
the year before that it screwed up the
entire NBA because if you're gonna if
you're not gonna have that cap where
guys take less money like you just
described the Warriors who's gonna stop
them but who's gonna stop a you know one
or two or three role players or guys who
may be starters to say I'd like to be
part of you know this boyband here at
Golden State is your scenario that maybe
something better comes along than
draymond Green and they say hey we can
get this guy so they might lose some
even if they lose a guy like clay or
draymond they can get somebody else
well claves the one I thought does clay
go you know I kind of like to have my
own team I kind of like to be the man I
I don't know you know we look at it and
go man you're getting paid well you're
playing for Championships like why would
you leave
you know there's jealousy there's envy
there's ego there's a lot of things that
play into that Dennis Scott is back with
us the NBA TV analyst we were just
talking about super teams I it almost
gets the feeling what you know LeBron
said Dennis is that hey you know if you
can't beat them you gotta join one you
think that's what LeBron is saying I'm
gonna just join us
hey don't begrudge me if I join a super
team well to that point Dan I don't
think LeBron is going to leave this time
around because I think LeBron is so
cerebral and he's looking around he's
saying
Dalila to even go to LA like I go to the
Clippers which i think is very enticing
if you sit down with Ballmer Jerry West
and now Doc Rivers it's interesting but
I don't think LeBron wants to start
completely over again at 33 34 years old
and answer your question I've talked to
clay numerous times clay do you want to
leave just like he said in the Western
Conference final he says I get paid
handsomely I'm playing with Steph Curry
I'm playing with Kevin Durant why would
I want to leave I know I'm leaning for a
champion I'm competing for a
championship every year so why would I
leave the song quote be the man I'm
looking at the scenarios here for LeBron
and I'm with you I think LeBron stays
one more year in Cleveland because he's
just not sure how everything is gonna
shake out where's Kawhi Leonard where's
Paul George what happens in the draft
what is Houston do with Chris Paul
Philadelphia's situation is fluid right
now so I just get the feeling that he's
gonna go let me let me sign up for one
more contract one more year here and
take another run and then decide to
leave after that what do you think of
that scenario and the reason that makes
sense Dan because wherever he leaves if
there's not enough talent where he goes
why leaves you still have Kevin Love you
have the eighth pick there's some other
movements that obviously Kobe Alton and
Dan Gilbert have to agree to it but his
move that you can make to keep LeBron
happy to stay versus him leaving it's
starting all over again
yeah and I'm looking at the fits here as
well and you know better than I do it
in Houston I can play with my teammates
but if we sort of like to have the ball
at the you know a lot it doesn't fit
Philadelphia now what has been Simmons
role if you go in and then is Joe LM
beat a role player with LeBron those
don't make sense to me the Lakers are a
year away I think from really sort of
getting their head above water and being
maybe a legitimate contender not
challenger to Golden State but so that's
when I look at this and I go unless
Kevin Durant's coming down the coast I
just can't imagine LeBron going yep let
me let me go to the Lakers and if you go
to the Lakers ball has to leave Ingram
has to leave Kuzma have to leave all
that young talent has to leave the
Lakers because there's no way you can
keep it bringing in LeBron or if you do
tray for colliding it to your point or
if you can entice Paul George to leave
Melo and Russell Westbrook to go back to
California so to speak so all those
scenarios you just said Dan doesn't make
sense along with Philadelphia I love Ben
Simmons but the reason we do Dan because
the ball isn't Ben Simmons his hands if
the Brian goes there now the ball goes
out of benefit with his hands now he's
out of the sectors I mentioned at the
top of the interview you're one of the
greatest shooters in your form is
something that I would teach to kids
in how to follow through and you know
your form is is is perfect but you look
at your shot you look at your range
compare that though and B I know you're
gonna be humble but compare yourself
with the Steph Curry
like do you have that range did you have
that range did you have that ability to
shoot that well from that far I have
that range and I thank you for saying
that there because technology in the way
we look at things are totally different
Tim Frank one of our media guys for MBA
said I remember being it another day
with Georgia Tech was playing another
game and you would take shots from the
hash mark before the game he said that's
the stuff that we didn't quote unquote
videotape back in the day and now we do
the difference is with Steph Curry is
he's a point guard he can bring the ball
up the court and souls he crosses
half-court he's in range
that's the difference
being say playing with Timmy playing
with Shaq I set off those guys so well
and that's how they would get my shot
off you look back on the Georgia Tech
days on what could have been it as much
talent as you guys had now you didn't
have it very long but you know said you
guys have won a national title I get
that question like that and I think
about it and playing with a guy like any
answer and Brian Oliver Malcolm Mackey
that was so much fun and to your point
it was only one year yeah I don't know
if it was if it was a reality if I came
back to school could I've gotten other
guys that kind of like to change forces
of the world it could possibly happen
because I believe in college everything
is so innocent and you're playing for
now versus when you get into the NBA
you're kind of playing for your future
Kenny Anderson was pretty special you
remember all the publicity around Kenny
yes I do they say he's the best player
coming out of New York since Lew
Alcindor
I said wait a minute that's Kareem
abdul-jabbar he's dead good he's only
six foot but the first time you saw him
on campus what did you think I was like
wow this kids know he's maybe a buck
fifty something west and he's so smooth
he's so skilled with the basketball the
ball handling the passing the first day
of practice I cut back door I didn't
think he saw me to ball him in the back
to that New York axel PRC's I think you
get it up and that's it never again
young fella give me the ball visit
shooters paradise 3d comm what do they
find in shooters Paradise 3d calm well
it's one of these things in my whole
life I realized that God blessed me to
shoot the basketball and you said it
earlier
I love to teach people about shooting
understanding that it starts with
confidence first put in the work I
started doing some t-shirts some had
some hoodies and things of that nature
at the end of the day when you're
watching the finals we've come down to
the simple thing of shot making if you
believe in yourself if you put them to
work you can become a better shooter I
can't guarantee you gonna make shots but
I know you become a better shooter if
you put in the right
work would you rather have steps Shawn
Kevin Durant shot or klay Thompson
klay Thompson shot is picture-perfect
Steph Curry has unlimited reigns and
Kevin Durant still reminds us he's still
the best scorer in the business do you
think Durant can end up the all-time
leading scorer bardo crazy injuries I
think you had the opportunity to do that
Danny here's why he's finally found a
system where he can be himself Steve
Kerr understands how good his talent is
and they play to it and now he's more
efficient than he was in the other okay
see who could you help more Ben Simmons
or Lonzo ball with their shot I think
Ben Simmons because of his size the ball
is going to be in his hands just like
LeBron James for the rest of his career
but can you make him a better shooter
yes I can make him a better shoot
because I believe was his size it's a
difference his size because he doesn't
need to become a better three-point
shooter he needs to become a better
shooter period I think people over
analyzed by saying all he was
three-point shot no he does not need a
three-point shot
he needs a better shot period well maybe
the Sixers can hire you Dennis shooters
Paradise 3d dot-com smack Berkeley for
me tonight it's a it's a good watch I
enjoyed watching it the other night you
with a see Webb and Grant Hill that'll
be on NBA TV Thank You Dennis a paper
you dare night Dennis Scott for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
you